light flickers
on the low ceiling
a horn is visible
or is it a tusk
antlers huge antlers diverge and reach
across the narrow cave
a vast herd of animals comes into view
deer horses bison and amongst them
stranger creatures beasts long dead in
this part of the world
orocks stretch along the walls whilst
giant deer are stalked by prides of cave
lions
the prehistoric people of lasso in
modern day france had come to these
caves for generations layering images of
fear and wonder on top of one another
like graffiti whose meaning and
significance only they could say
these elaborate caves contain no dates
no indication of when they were created
yet the modern day absence of aurochs
giant deer and cave lions hints
at a great age
a time when these exotic animals roamed
the valleys around lasso
today carbon dating has revealed that
these talented artists lived around 17
000 years ago during the upper
paleolithic
a time
of great struggle
for much of the world was in the grip
of an ice age the likes of which
humanity had never seen before
things had been cold on earth with ice
caps at the poles and chilly northern
winters for most of human history but
about 26 and a half thousand years ago
it took a turn
for the worse average temperatures
plummeted to around 6 degrees celsius
colder than today and ice sheets grew
and extended down from the arctic circle
to the middle of europe and the north
american continent around a quarter of
the world's land surface was totally
covered in ice and sea level dropped 125
meters lower than it is now
this period known to scientists as the
last glacial maximum saw the northern
hemisphere transformed making survival
tough for the paleolithic humans who
called it home these glacial conditions
created cold and dry weather with strong
winds blowing dust into the atmosphere
but little rainfall to rain it back out
deep red sunsets would be reflected from
the icy permafrost and tundra that
spread across europe as fur-clad bands
of early humans roamed back and forth
across the edge of the ice sheet
stalking long extinct monsters
life in the ice age was hard but lasso
was a refuge for these people a
sheltered spot to regroup and reflect on
their hunting victories and losses
of course many other bands of humans may
have retreated south where temperatures
were warmer and the ice was a distant
memory
we don't know if the lasso tribes
survived through the last glacial
maximum
but certainly the human race clung on in
the refuges away from the ice this was
because once the last ice age was
certainly intense
it wasn't
global there were plenty of places on
earth that weren't
frozen the grip of this 5 000 year
winter may have been hard for humanity
but there is evidence for much harder
times in earth's history
times when there would have been no
escape from the ice
at all
when it wasn't even certain if the earth
would be able to break free for just
over half a billion years before the
lasso made their home
a spectacular event
may have struck
our world
an event known informally by climate
scientists today
a snowball earth
but did these total global glaciations
really happen
how could such extreme ice ages even
occur
and what would they have meant for earth
and its precious precarious
life
[Music]
the cave of the hundred mammoths is a
fascinating cave system in france
covered with engravings and drawings of
ancient mammoths they ruled the earth at
the same time as the lasso peoples not
only in france but all over the world
and so our documentary recommendation on
curiosity stream this month is ancient
yellowstone mammoth country a
fascinating dive into the fertile
hunting grounds for paleontologists atop
the ancient supervolcano ancient
yellowstone is a great series in general
and just the tip of the iceberg when it
comes to the thousands of documentaries
available on curiosity stream on topics
ranging from ancient history to deep
space curiosity stream is also a bargain
at less than 20 dollars a year and has
fantastic new shows popping up every
week so go to curiositystream.com
forward slash history of the earth to
sign up and using the promo code history
of the earth will save you 25 percent
bringing a full year down to
14.99 just over a dollar a month thanks
to curiositystream for supporting
education on youtube
[Music]
douglas mauson trudges on and on through
the snow flurries and blistering
antarctic wind
sliding one foot in front of the other
his skis slice through the fresh snow
and his poles impale the drifts
he barely feels the weight of the sled
behind him anymore after three years in
the field it is as much a part of his
body as his own arms or legs
but now on the last stretch of his final
journey mawson
is numb
inside and out
two months earlier in november 1912 the
australian geologist had set out with
two other explorers xavier mertz and
belgrave ninis to map the coastline of
the australian portion of antarctica the
expedition had gone well for the first
five weeks with the three men and a raft
of sled dogs speeding across the white
featureless expanse a disaster had
struck when ninis's sled fell through
the snow covering a crevasse and he his
dogs on more than half of the party's
supplies disappeared into the heart
of the glacier
ninis was never found and mawson and
mertz turned back immediately with so
few provisions for themselves and the
remaining huskies the pair were forced
to eat their own dogs
exhausted sick broken in mind and spirit
but with still more than 100 miles to go
before base camp mertz took a turn
for the worse
he became delirious biting off the tip
of his own finger raging violently and
suffering seizures before falling into a
coma and dying
it later transpired that he had been
poisoned by vitamin a from the sled
dog's livers
mawson was alone
but had no choice to continue or face
death himself he eventually made the
lonely journey back to his camp but his
bad luck
followed him back
he finally arrived to discover that the
ship due to take him home had already
left just a few hours earlier forcing
him to spend another winter on the ice
with more than enough time to mourn his
lost companions
despite these horrors upon returning
home mawson was awarded with a
knighthood and his venture had uncovered
such a wealth of biological and
geological data that it took 30 years to
fully unfold
though he did later return to antarctica
mawson spent much of the rest of his
career studying the geology of his
native australia as professor of geology
at the university of adelaide he had
ample opportunity to consider the
geological history of the entire country
and there was perhaps no one more suited
to interpret the mysterious rocks that
researchers and prospectors were
discovering
across a swathe of the sun-baked
continent there appeared to be almost 1
000 miles of galacial sediments
they were clearly out of place but they
were also incredibly ancient dating back
to the neoproterozoic period long before
the evolution of animals mawson
doubtless drew on both his geological
and antarctic experience when he made a
remarkable
suggestion
perhaps he said the whole of australia
had once been entombed in ice in some
kind of global glaciation
how else could you explain the freezing
of a place as hot as australia if not by
the freezing of the entire world
mawson's geological and glaciological
reasoning were sound but they failed to
account for one thing
continental drift
as the theories of continental drift and
subsequently plate tectonics gained
ground they helped geologists to solve
the puzzle of these seemingly
incongruous deposits
accepting that the continental masses
travelled across the face of the earth
as crustal plates scraped collided were
destroyed and made anew permitted places
like australia to become glaciated
without the need for a worldwide freeze
during the neoproterozoic it turned out
australia simply lay closer to the poles
and was therefore more likely to
experience normal polar conditions
plate tectonics may have undermined
mawson's conclusions but that wasn't the
end for his ideas
as geologists learned to reconstruct the
shuffling of continents through
geological time new sedimentary
conundrums began to present themselves
for one galacial deposits have been
found in greenland and on the arctic
island of svalbard
on the surface this is perhaps not
surprising since both of these places
experience long polar nights and
year-round freezing conditions
but these particular deposits date from
around 650 million years ago when
tectonic reconstructions suggest that
svalbard and greenland lay at tropical
latitudes
ancient ice in australia may not
indicate a global glacier but ancient
ice on greenland
does
but it's not just these two places that
hint at an extraordinary neoproterozoic
glaciation
all over the world geologists use
elemental isotopes and local
relationships to find the age of their
rocks and they use the alignment of
ferromagnetic minerals like hematite and
magnetite to the earth's magnetic field
to find the latitudes at which these
rocks were formed
finally they use clues in the rocks
themselves to reconstruct the paleo
environment and by extension the paleo
climate at that particular location
researchers began to find
characteristically glacial deposits from
the late neoproterozoic
worldwide
they include chaotic unsorted sediments
known as tillites which are created by
the action of glaciers as they churn up
existing rock and deposit it there are
also drop stones large cobbles or
pebbles that appear to have been dropped
from above into much finer layered
sediment without having to invoke
mysterious rock-slinging deities these
anomalies can be explained by melting
icebergs dropping their sediment load
far out to sea passing glaciers can also
polish rock surfaces and leave long
straight scratches known as striations
and lakes that form from glacial melt
water record accumulate finely layered
sediments at their bottoms called valves
which reveal the seasonal ebb and flow
of melting waters
all of these features have been found in
rocks from the late neoproterozoic
and most importantly regardless of the
latitude in which they were formed
drop stones valves and tilites from near
the equator lead to the inescapable
conclusion that there was ice here
and the planet must have looked very
different to today
not only that but late neoproterozoic
deposits contain some rare and unique
rock types that are hard to explain
without drastic climatic and
oceanographic transformation
banded iron formations which disappeared
from the planet some one and a half
billion years earlier now make their
reappearance in rocks from 700 million
years ago their presence implies oceans
that were occasionally anoxic something
that would only be possible in the
neoproterozoic waters if something was
stopping gases from being exchanged
between the atmosphere and ocean
something perhaps like an immense
uninterrupted ice sheet that covered the
global ocean like a shell
finally in a stroke of remarkable
geological synchronicity researchers
have consistently found a single type of
rock laid down worldwide directly above
the widespread glacial deposits no one
is sure exactly how or why the cab
carbonates formed all around the world
all at the same time but a leading
explanation involves the sudden influx
of new material from the land surface
into an ocean that had become strongly
acidic with carbonic acid alternatively
the cab carbonates may just represent
the moment the oceans breathed again
after a long and constricting global
freeze
[Music]
and so all of these pieces of geological
evidence seemed to point to the same
remarkable conclusion
in the late neoproterozoic
starting around 750 million years ago
the earth experienced an intense ice age
that saw widespread freezing of the land
and ocean
a global glaciation that caused ice to
extend from the poles right down to the
tropics
perhaps even meeting at the equator
an ice house world that transformed the
earth from a watery paradise to a barren
almost lifeless ball of ice
and what's more this probably didn't
happen once but up to four times in
quick succession right up until the dawn
of animal life
american geologist joseph kirschvink
aptly named these global glaciations
snowball earths for the way they turned
our diverse blue marble into nothing
more than a featureless white orb
but the period of geological time in
which many of these extreme events occur
is known as the cryogenian after the
greek for frost
now that neoproterozoic rocks have been
studied in detail the individual
glaciations are named after the rock
formations where they were first
identified
the stereo glaciation is the oldest
occurring between 750 and 660 million
years ago it's followed shortly after by
the marinoan ice age from 650 to 635
million years ago records suggest that a
very brief global glaciation followed
579 million years ago and the final
snowball earth is known as the
bakernurian glaciation and it marks the
very end of the proterozoic period
lasting from 549 to 530
million years ago
[Music]
it's worth noting that these are not the
first times that the planet has been
plunged into icy purgatory around two
and a half billion years ago the earth
was put into a 300 million year long
deep freeze as a result of the great
oxygenation event and the atmospheric
changes that followed but more than
fifteen hundred million years have
passed since then and the neoproterozoic
earth is a very different world
life has become complex cooperative and
the stakes are higher than ever
just how hard will it be to survive
on a cryogenian earth
[Music]
icy comet speeds through the solar
system on a slingshot course towards the
sun
flung on this fateful trajectory
millions of years before from its home
in the distant kuiper belt it has swung
and looped around its star nearly a
million times
but the lonely comet's days are numbered
this may well be its last stellar tour
with every approach the sun's heat
evaporates some of its icy mantle
sending it streaming behind in a
glorious rainbow-lit tail and the once
magnificent icy asteroid is now but a
shadow of its former self
nevertheless on it flies
it sails past neptune and uranus cold
ice giants lurking in the dark onwards
and inwards to saturn girdled by rings
and looming jupiter with its unruly
moons
as it pierces through the relative
clutter of the rocky asteroid belt the
sun's warmth begins to grow
and the comet
begins to glow
on it goes into the inner solar system
and past the already dry and dusty mars
it's still 700 million years before
humanity will evolve to recognize its
reddish glow in the night sky but mars
has already lost its life-giving
atmosphere and oceans to the unforgiving
solar wind only a little water remains
frozen at the red planet's poles
closer still to the sun and the melting
comet's days are numbered
the earth's single gigantic moon is its
penultimate flyby and as the earth
itself grows larger in the comet's
sights and the sun's heat eats away at
the comet's core
two frozen bodies glow as brightly
as one another
on one side of the sky an icy asteroid
is about to meet its end
and on the earth an entire icy planet
there is
no end
in sight
it sits squarely in the warmth of the
sun's habitable zone and yet not a drop
of liquid water is to be seen
in the clear night skies above this
snowball earth the comet disintegrates
and evaporates into a superheated vapor
but on the planet's surface the big
freeze continues on
a crushing global winter with no easy
way out
from the air the blindingly sunlit
dayside is cast into sharp relief by its
shadowed night
separated by a smooth terminus
uninterrupted by either mountain or
valley but the planet's night side is
not completely dark the bright white
surface reflects the star and moonlight
giving an entire hemisphere an eerie
grey glow
yet it's almost impossible to see the
planet spin as the featureless globe
slides beneath its shadows time on earth
during the cryogenian is just as
undifferentiated as its geography
seasons pass winter to summer but with
no visible change on the surface
all
remains white
years decades and millennia pass through
cycles of solar activity and subtle
changes in earth's orbit and spin
but still there is no visible change on
the surface
it's easy to lose track of time
and before you know it
90 million years have passed
it is only when on the surface that it's
possible to differentiate between icy
land and icy ocean the sea ice appears
as an endless smooth expanse interrupted
only by larger icebergs trapped and
frozen in place but approaching the
hidden shoreline the ice cracks and
heaves in chaotic slow motion the result
of tidal forces bulging the still liquid
ocean beneath many meters of ice
there are long flat white coastal plains
that then rise to a rolling rocky
landscape but all is smoothed and
softened by the indiscriminating blanket
of snow and ice
only occasionally is a sharp rocky ridge
or peak visible blown free of snow and
ice by the unforgiving wind
indeed wind is likely the only weather
that this frozen ball will experience
with temperatures at the equator as low
as those on modern-day antarctica
there's no spare energy in the
atmosphere for brewing storms or rain
clouds
ice covers every surface becoming a
barrier to evaporation and making it
extremely difficult to pump water vapor
into the air without clouds through the
night there's little retention of heat
close to the surface and at night
especially the temperatures plummet even
further
it is unfathomably dry and cold
but still
the wind blows
from warmer dayside to colder nightside
or from extremely cold mountain tops to
only very cold shorelines the wind
blows uninterrupted across the
featureless surface it whips loose snow
and ice crystals into a sparkling ice
mist and rivers of powder blue across
the ground
it would be quite beautiful if it
weren't so deadly
for the surface is most certainly
inhospitable
to life
atop the snow and ice there is none of
the water that every life form needs to
survive and since snow and ice cover the
entire globe there would seem to be
nowhere left for earth's fragile
inhabitants to cling on
and yet
cling on they do
the ever innovative biological
metabolism is capable of endless
variations by 750 million years ago
bacteria algae and the unicellular
ancestors of animals had already adapted
to inhabit almost every corner of the
oceans and inland waters and were
beginning to creep their way onto land
from the shores too so when the earth
froze over life may have lost most of
its territory but it was able to persist
in whatever stronghold whatever refugia
it might find
while on the grand global scale the
earth is featurelessly frozen there will
always be some fine scale variation some
tiny cracks in the facade that life can
exploit
beneath the thick oceanic ice shelf the
oceans are not frozen to the bottom they
might be pitch black they might be
anoxic and stagnant but there are
microbes that can still eke out in
existence on such meager rations
life's ancestral refuge still exists at
the very bottom of these stagnant oceans
too hydrothermal vents pump warm
mineral-rich water out onto the sea
floor and they are colonized by
chemilitho autotrophs able to get all
they need from the minerals that build
the underwater volcanic chimneys there
are opportunities for the
photosynthesizers too even though the
freezing temperatures at the sunlit
surface are at first grossly
incompatible with these organisms need
for light
but again cracks in the facade leave
space for algae to scrape by
where the sea ice has heaved and cracked
and changed its shape a million times
pockets of water could become trapped
close enough to the surface to receive a
faint life-giving glimmer
similarly as the days and seasons come
and go some ice inevitably thins and
cracks when exposed to the unforgiving
glare of the midday or mid-summer sun
producing small areas of translucency or
even open water
it would freeze again when the sun sets
or winter rolls around but life has
taken its chance and can sleep out the
coldest times in sun-fattened dormancy
microbial life is even able to build its
own habitable microcosm on the surface
of the ice creating and expanding dark
water-filled pits that riddled the ice
surface like swiss cheese
known as kryokanites these vertical
holes begin to form when the sunlight
seizes up the dark color of dust grains
trapped within the ice warming it up
more than its surroundings which allows
it to melt the ice around it as the hole
expands it captures more of the warming
dust and it's colonized by dark coloured
snow algae that accelerates the warming
and melting effect
indeed even when the world is at its
coldest these cryoconites are proof that
life not only finds a way but helps to
engineer its own way too
and so as remarkable as it may seem even
as earth plunged into an apparently
eternal ice age it was not accompanied
by a mass extinction of life there's no
evidence of any great dying or of the
loss of any major branch of the tree of
life
unlike the last deep freeze more than
one and a half billion years earlier
where scientists believe up to 99
of all living things on the planet
perished organisms seem to have muddled
through unscathed
a remarkable demonstration of what 1.5
billion years of evolution and
diversification can do for life's
resilience in the face of seemingly
impossible odds
[Music]
planet earth today is in the midst of a
climate crisis
since the industrial revolution we have
been pumping carbon dioxide and
greenhouse gases into the atmosphere at
a remarkable rate
this revolution transformed how we live
work and play and fossil fuels and now
as invisibly essential to our lives as
water is to fish
but the carbon they release doesn't
belong in our atmosphere it was locked
away hundreds of millions of years ago
as part of a natural cycle playing out
on geological time scales we have broken
the wheel for our own immediate gain and
are now suffering the consequences
overwhelming scientific evidence now
points to a single conclusion that human
activity is causing the earth to warm at
its fastest rate for tens of millions of
years
while this in itself is bad news things
get much worse when we consider the
effects of this unprecedented
anthropogenic warming as the planet
warms it gets harder for ice to remain
covering the poles every year during the
arctic summer the sea ice retreats
further than it did before and soon we
might expect the watery north pole to be
completely exposed
but changes aren't just happening at sea
[Music]
the land surfaces in the arctic are also
frozen as permafrost down many hundreds
of meters in places ice turns soft soil
into sediment as hard as concrete
impenetrable to water and air much of
northern canada northern europe and
siberia are gripped by a year-round
permafrost that stunts and stifles any
organism that would choose to live here
but global warming is eating away at
this permafrost too
all over the northern hemisphere the
thickness of this frozen layer is
diminishing thawing and in the process
relinquishing an unexpectedly damaging
cargo methane that was created as dead
plants and animals decayed within the
permafrost is now able to escape into
the atmosphere
and methane is 25 times more potent as a
heat trapping greenhouse gas than carbon
dioxide
its release into the air only helps the
planet to warm up more causing more
melting of the arctic permafrost more
release of methane more warming and so
on
this so-called positive feedback is a
vicious escalating spiral that could see
the already dire effects of
human-induced climate change suddenly
become
catastrophically worse
the arctic alone is thought to contain
1500 billion tons of carbon which is
almost twice the amount of greenhouse
gases already in the atmosphere for
context human activity over the last 250
years has increased the amount of these
gases by just 50 percent but the
positive feedback loop in the arctic
could see it jump by 200 percent in mere
decades
scientists suspect that we have already
passed the tipping point for this
climatic death spiral and the best we
can do now is figure out how to weather
the storm
sixty years ago in the 1960s humanity
was as yet blissfully unaware of the
coming climatic apocalypse with the
development of modern meteorological
methods scientists were just beginning
to understand the interconnections of
weather and climate across the globe and
resembling some of the first climatic
models that predicted long-term trends
in environmental conditions worldwide
during this meteorological renaissance a
soviet climate scientist named mikhail
budiko perhaps inspired by the brutal
winters that assailed his home city of
leningrad began considering the effects
of different degrees of ice cover on the
global climate
as anyone who's considered dressing in a
hot country with a test light coloured
materials reflect the sun's radiation
more effectively than dark coloured ones
the dark fathomless depths of the ocean
soak up 94 percent of what the sun
dishes out whereas the same ocean
covered by ice will reflect up to 70
percent of that radiation this so-called
albedo effect means that cold
ice-covered areas tend to stay cold
because they bounce back the one thing
that can warm them up
it is the beginning of a positive
feedback loop and buddhico's model
assembled the mathematics to discover
how far that spiraling rabbit hole went
his models showed that if temperatures
on earth dropped enough to allow ice
cover to reach latitudes of around 25 to
30 degrees north and south level with
texas egypt and south africa then the
cooling albedo effect would outweigh the
warmth from the remaining ocean forcing
ice to advance all the way to the
equator and so external temperature
drivers don't have to be as extreme as
one might imagine and the earth's own
escalating feedback would take it the
rest of the way puriko's reasoning and
mathematics was sound but he was quick
to doubt his own work the model
suggested that once ice reached the
equator then the completely ice-covered
globe would reach a new thermal
equilibrium and losing any mechanism by
which it might warm up again essentially
if ice ever reached a latitude of 30
degrees then his work suggested the
earth would be plunged into an
inescapable global ice age
from which there could be
no thermodynamic reprieve
as a result he squarely dismissed the
idea that this had ever happened in
earth's history
for if it had we would still be living
on snowball earth
nevertheless there is strong geological
evidence for tropical glacial deposits
during the neoproterozoic and with
positive feedback in the loop we can
reasonably expect that to mean ice
extended all the way to the equator but
budico's model does offer a little help
to scientists as they search for reasons
for the global snowball we only need to
find mechanisms that can create a
tropical ice age rather than an
equatorial one although average global
temperatures for much of the cryogenian
would have hovered around -50 degrees
celsius we are only looking for a
mechanism that can drive average
temperatures down to near freezing point
and for that there are a few viable
options
[Music]
the first snowball earth also known as
the huronian glaciation around 2.4
billion years ago was likely caused by a
sudden and catastrophic change in the
earth's atmospheric composition the
appearance of organisms capable of
making energy by oxygenic photosynthesis
saw oxygen begin to replace greenhouse
gases in the atmosphere photosynthetic
algae consumed carbon dioxide and
emitted oxygen which in turn reacted
with any methane in the air turning it
into the much less potent carbon dioxide
which in turn became fuel for more
photosynthesis
it was this intrinsic change in the
earth's heat balance in how much heat
the atmosphere was able to trap that saw
global temperatures drop and then as a
result of positive feedback
plummet
a similar situation could have occurred
during the cryogenian although the
mechanism for atmospheric transformation
is harder to pin down perhaps a
particularly productive time for
photosynthetic life saw an uncommonly
large amount of carbon dioxide pulled
out of the atmosphere or perhaps a
particular configuration of land masses
was conducive to intense weathering that
consumed carbon dioxide through chemical
rather than biological means however
there is little evidence in the rock
record of either biological or chemical
drawdown if earth's levels of insulating
carbon dioxide suddenly dropped
then they did so without leaving a
conclusive trace
if there is no evidence for intrinsic
long-term changes to trigger a snowball
earth then perhaps the cause was more
acute in the form of a sudden and
extreme change in incoming solar
radiation
modern scientists believe that a
relatively short-lived event has the
capacity to trigger extreme planetary
cooling providing its intense enough
perhaps those changes came from outside
the earth itself as the sun went through
a particularly quiet period with much
reduced activity or a combination of
orbital changes that seized the planet's
tilt and orbital path subtly tweaked to
produce intense polar winters
alternatively a reduction of solar
radiation could have come
from within
an eruption of an immense super volcano
the size of yellowstone or larger would
release so much ash and reflective gases
into the atmosphere that they would
encircle the globe and block solar rays
for many years to come
the planet would be plunged into a dim
nuclear winter and by the time the dust
has cleared the positive feedback is
well underway
one final piece of the puzzle seems to
be the distribution of continents across
the earth's surface and there is a
growing body of evidence that suggests
that a large supercontinent
close to the equator is a necessity if
you are to end up with a frozen snowball
earth in general continents are cooler
and more reflective than the darkness of
the open ocean so they could help to
accelerate and exacerbate the cooling
process
but tropical continents go one step
further normally the weathering of land
surfaces pulls carbon dioxide out of the
air and so tends to reduce the global
warmth by nibbling away at the
greenhouse effect
it is the beginning of a stabilizing
negative feedback that keeps conditions
within certain narrow bands
when global temperatures drop below a
certain level the land becomes cold and
the rate of weathering here slows down
there is less carbon dioxide being
removed from the atmosphere allowing the
greenhouse effect to bloom and warm the
planet once again
however when there is land at the
tropics this stabilizing negative
feedback has less hold over the global
climate land that is exposed at tropical
latitude is much more likely to continue
to be weathered even as global
temperatures fall
so temperatures are dropping but so are
levels of insulating carbon dioxide
there is no negative feedback here and
the cooling can continue uninterrupted
it's a compelling thermodynamic theory
except for one important detail for all
other serious glaciations through
earth's history there has been land at
the poles providing a surface on which
ice can grow
was their land at the poles or at the
equator at the beginning of the
cryogenian
unfortunately conclusive reconstructions
are difficult because of a lack of
suitable sediment
[Music]
and so with more and more evidence that
it did in fact happen
there is one big question that we need
to answer
it is clear
that this was not
terminal
indeed a few million years after these
events the cambrian explosion took place
a remarkable unparalleled
diversification of life on earth an
event clearly impossible on a planet
covered with ice from pole to equator
we need to find an explanation for how
the world recovered
just how
did the snowball earth
end
professor joseph kirschvink has made a
name for himself
as the real life
iron man
for more than 30 years he has walked the
crowded caltech campus contemplating the
many things we stand to learn by
studying magnetic materials what they
can tell us about biology the history of
life and the history of the earth itself
it was he who first suggested that
banded iron formations might come about
through a wide scale global glaciation
that effectively cut off ocean
circulation and in doing so he was the
first to coin the term snowball earth
and yet unlike michael boudicco who
foresaw apocalypse in positive feedback
loops kirschvink was not so disturbed by
the consequences of such a glaciation
climate models could only tell you so
much he reasoned and the earth is a
complex system that could not be
described by simple energy in energy out
nevertheless the doomsday scenario
predicted by boudicco had seized the
imaginations of the public and
scientists alike and the theorized
finality of a snowball earth has been
used to cast doubt on the theory
[Music]
indeed to this day there is disagreement
in the scientific community as to the
true extent of the neoproterozoic
glaciations in order to make a claim for
an extraordinary global ice event there
must be extraordinary evidence to
support it for one the deposits must be
unquestionably glacial they must have
definitely formed at low latitudes and
no other rock types should have formed
at the same time
unfortunately 700 million years has been
plenty of time for the clarity of that
evidence to become obscured rocks that
have been interpreted as glacial tills
and iceberg drop stones could have
formed by other means with no need for
ice at all the paleomagnetic evidence
that points to tropical latitudes for
these rocks relies on the assumption
that the earth's magnetic field has
always been what it is today had the
magnetic poles wandered that our sense
of direction on the neoproterozoic earth
would be irrevocably skewed
and finally it is difficult to sort
through the precise chronology of rocks
that are found all over the world
geologists usually use fossils that date
to a very specific period of time but in
the neoproterozoic before the appearance
of large-scale fossil groups that
precision just isn't available
and so since none of this evidence is as
solid as it could be some researchers
have suggested that the neoproterozoic
events were no different to other
glacial periods in earth's history like
the one we are living in right now there
is ice at the poles and at high
elevations and ice sheets wax and wane
through the seasons and millennia but
there is no
global freeze
or alternatively an intermediate
situation prevailed instead of a
snowball there may have been a slush
ball earth which saw ice extend down to
subtropical latitudes while the equator
remained ice free or with a band of thin
seasonal ice
this would have allowed some
continuation of the hydrological cycle
through these periods and would help to
explain some of the sedimentary rocks
that seem to form in open water or from
moving ice
indeed it is important to remember here
that the earth is never static
the movement of tectonic plates across
the earth's crust could have
periodically cracked the planet's icy
shell
opening up pools of open water and
offering some reprieve from the global
freeze
however even if ice came to hold our
planet in its full grip in a full-blown
snowball earth
joseph kirschvink still saw a way to
escape
while the earth is frozen many of its
dynamic processes and cycles come to a
halt without open ocean the water cycle
ceases without life and water the carbon
cycle winds down to a mere trickle
that there is nothing about the freezing
of the surface that stops the churning
of the planet's interior tectonic
cycling continues as crustal plates are
created and destroyed at their margins
with accompanying earthquakes vents and
volcanoes and so this is where a [ __ ]
in the snowball's icy armor appears
active volcanoes continue to pump gases
including carbon dioxide and methane
into the atmosphere ordinarily that
carbon would be cycled back down into
the earth via the process of weathering
as acid rain forming from dissolved
carbon dioxide eats away at the rocks or
abundant to life forms in the open ocean
can draw it down and lock it away in the
carbon of their bodies or limestone of
their shells
but without either of these cycles
working efficiently the carbon dioxide
stays stuck in the atmosphere and builds
up and up over millions of years of
volcanic outgassing
we are currently witnessing what happens
to the earth when there is an excess of
carbon dioxide in the atmosphere the gas
traps heat and warms the earth via the
greenhouse effect and the more gas there
is the more effective this process is
and so joseph kirschvink saw how a
snowball earth would eventually
overbalance and collapse thanks to a
supercharged ultra greenhouse effect
from accumulated volcanic
gas
in time the earth
sets itself right
biology itself may have been a passenger
through these wild swings in earth's
climate but as with the earth's eternal
engine the march of evolution never
slows or sits still while we can't know
for sure how life scraped by through the
intense cold and then sudden heating of
the planet it's fair to assume that it
experienced some intense pressures to
adapt and survive in new extreme
conditions
as such it may well be that the snowball
earth periods of the neoproterozoic
acted as evolutionary triggers driving
innovations that would come to shape the
future of life on the earth and the
oceans for instance aquatic algae
suffered through the global freeze as
their shallow water habitats were iced
over
but if they found a way to survive with
a little less water perhaps attaching to
and feeding on the solid exposed tidal
flats then they would acquire all the
adaptations necessary for taking the big
future leap to becoming land plants
and so the ends of the snowball periods
coincide with some major biological
revolutions the enigmatic ediacaran
organisms the first multicellular and
truly macroscopic communities to appear
did so less than 10 million years after
the end of the gasquier glaciation and
the final baikonurian glaciation may
have actually contributed to one of the
biggest radiations of life in the
history of the planet
the cambrian explosion of animals
the question still remains however as to
how much the living component of our
planet contributed to causing these
glaciations in the first place
ice ages may have kick-started evolution
but did evolutionary changes trigger the
ice ages too
certainly the mechanism is there if some
adaptation suddenly allowed life to
surge forward in its productivity
perhaps able to inhabit a new
environmental niche or exploit a new
more efficient biochemical pathway then
it could have led to a tangible
reduction in greenhouse gases enough to
trigger a snowball earth
this is almost certainly how the first
global huronian ice age came about and
that huronian period eventually saw the
blossoming of eukaryotic life forms and
the evolution of sex
so it's not unreasonable to imagine that
the cryogenian freezes could have been
influenced by and in turn influential to
the evolution
of life
although the snowball earths may have
been some of the most testing times in
our planet's history promising unending
global winter and the annihilation of
earth's most precious cargo these big
freezes have never yet followed through
on their threats
in fact when considered in the context
of all geological time they seem almost
to be global resets a chance for
processes worldwide to stop and restart
perhaps beginning on a new course that
would come to shape the world as we know
it
it may be that far from threatening our
planet snowball earths have been
necessary for creating our modern
temperate
earth
[Music]
you've been watching the entire history
of the earth
don't forget to like and subscribe and
leave a comment to tell us what you
think
i will see you
next time
[Music]